on en parlait en début d'émission le
bazar culturel théâtre social itinérant
et la mairie de Cernay-la-Ville ont mis
en place un projet culturel innovant au
sein du Petit Moulin des vaux-de-cernée
samedi dernier des jeunes de la commune
ont présenté une visite théâtralisée
avec des résidents du centre
d'hébergement d'urgence pour demandeurs
d'asile à Bonnelles pour en parler avec
nous claire Chéré la mère de
Cernay-la-Ville et Alex adarjean le
coordinateur du bazar culturel bonsoir
bonsoir alors en début d'émission claire
chéri vous nous avez un petit peu
expliqué d'où est venu cette initiative
maintenant quel est quel a été
l'objectif de ce projet culturel de
cette visite théâtralisée
[Musique]
déjà juste une précision les jeunes qui
ont participé sont des jeunes de Cernay
mais aussi des jeunes de la vallée
puisque le lycée de la vallée a été un
peu un relais pour nous pour
trouver des jeunes qui étaient
intéressés et donc ça a permis aussi
d'étendre d'ouvrir un peu les portes du
village aux jeunes des villes ou
villages voisins de Cernay-la-Ville et
de la Vallée de Chevreuse
et donc l'objectif est bien évidemment
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure c'était
de tisser du lien et de permettre à des
personnes donc les réfugiés du centre de
Bonnel et les jeunes de la vallée
d'entrer en contact et de réaliser un
projet culturel un projet
qui leur permettent ensuite une certaine
forme d'expression théâtrale et puis du
coup de à travers ça à la fois de tisser
du lien mais aussi de raconter une
histoire et donc d'aller chercher un peu
au fond d'eux des choses importantes à
partager aussi avec le public qui est
venu ce jour-là et justement pour
rebondir à ce que vous disiez vous aviez
réussi à mobiliser des jeunes grâce aux
établissements scolaires comment est-ce
que vous aviez mobilisé justement ces
réfugiés comment est-ce que sont portés
volontaires ou comment ça s'est passé
alors qu'en fait quand on a obtenu le la
subvention du département en fait il
fallait justement avoir des partenaires
et donc nous nous sommes associés avec
une association qui s'appelle solidarité
accompagnement pour les migrants et qui
travaillent qui avec les réfugiés de
Bonnel et donc ils ont été notre notre
relais en fait auprès des migrants et
donc eux ils ont présenté le projet Alex
aussi y est allé pour leur présenter le
projet et les personnes qui étaient
enthousiastes à l'idée de ce projet donc
sont venus ce jour-là ce jour-là l'idée
c'était de les rencontrer en fait en
amont des répétitions on a demandé du
stage de théâtre pour que des gens on se
connaissent parce que la relation de
confiance c'est aussi très importante
que ce soit avec les jeunes comme avec
les migrants d'ailleurs il y a pas de il
y a pas de différence là dessus et donc
le fait on se connaisse déjà c'était
à facilité en fait le travail qu'on a pu
faire parce que du coup ils sont venus
aussi non seulement pour faire du
théâtre mais aussi pour qu'on passe un
moment ensemble voilà et juste par
rapport aux objectifs sur ce que disait
claire j'ajouterai aussi que dans dans
un processus de médiation culturelle
très souvent nous on a le public cible
là en l'occurrence ça aurait pu être les
migrants et donc très souvent on va
monter une action à destination de ce
public et c'est eux qui vont venir on va
essayer de leur rendre accessible un
patrimoine là l'idée c'est un petit peu
de prendre le parti inverse c'est à dire
on leur met le patrimoine à disposition
donc là en l'occurrence c'était le petit
moulin et donc on construit la visite
avec eux donc ce n'est plus le public
auquel on va destiner une visite mais
c'est eux qui vont s'approprier le
monument à leur façon et en faire
quelque chose et le fait de le faire en
plus avec des jeunes bah évidemment ça
crée du lien et ça ça donne une approche
qui est totalement différente de ce
qu'on peut voir traditionnel et
justement
être réalisé samedi dernier je vous
propose de regarder le reportage et on
continue d'en parler juste après
une visite pas comme les autres samedi
11 mars les Yvelinois de passage au
Petit Moulin des voies de Cernay ont pu
découvrir le bâtiment d'une manière
originale
[Musique]
le bazar culturel théâtre social
itinérant à réaliser une visite
théâtralisée sur le thème du voyage et
de l'identité avec des jeunes cernesiens
et des résidents du centre d'hébergement
d'urgence pour demandeurs d'asile de
Bonnel c'était vraiment de créer du
mélange entre les cultures et surtout de
trouver un
instant de partage entre chacun on a
tous vécu des événements à un moment qui
ont marqué notre vie quel que soit nos
parcours quel que soit l'endroit où l'on
se trouve la langue qu'on parle et donc
l'idée c'était de retrouver du commun à
partir de ça
2021 je vis en Colombie j'ai étudié
administration publique Louisa Lopez et
colombienne arrivait en France en
janvier 2022 elle fait partie des cinq
migrants participants à ce projet
culturel j'ai trop que c'est vraiment
l'important c'est super bien parce que
les spectacles aussi nous montre comment
c'est la réalité des différentes
personnes qui avaient des différents
lieux de ces histoires c'est totalement
différent et aujourd'hui on peut trouver
tout le monde ici pour nous compter
cette histoire
et pour les aider à compter ces
histoires 5 jeunes de la commune de
Cernay qui ont bien voulu s'ouvrir aux
cultures étrangères
d'autres personnes que potentiellement
je le connaissais pas je sais pas
comment ça se passait au final c'est
très bien passé j'ai passé une très
bonne semaine avec eux le Centre
d'hébergement de demandeurs d'asile de
Bonnelles accueille une centaine de
réfugiés au-delà de l'apprentissage de
la langue française de nombreuses
activités sont mises en place pour les
sortir de leur quotidien comme cette
visite théâtralisée au Petit Moulin des
Hauts de Cernay
alors comme on a pu le voir dans le
reportage on a cette participante Louisa
Lopez qui est colombienne elle parle
français et ce qu'il y a eu une barrière
aussi du langage avec les autres
personnes avec qui vous avez pu
travailler ah oui juste une petite
précision Louisa en fait travaille
travaille au Petit Moulin elle fait pas
partie du groupe de migrants donc elle a
cette particularité en plus mais alors
oui sur la barrière de la langue bon on
a travaillé beaucoup avec la gestuelle
et puis en fait au bout d'un moment il y
a un langage commun qui s'est créé aussi
et puis ce qui a été compliqué au départ
à la fois pour moi comme pour eux ça a
été de se dire les choses clairement et
puis moi au début je j'osais peut-être
pas leur
demander si s'ils avaient bien compris
etc et puis après au bout d'un moment ça
se faisait assez naturellement quand je
disais tu as compris il me disait non
prenait et puis voilà quoi et comment
est-ce que vous avez réussi à tisser du
lien entre
ces réfugiés et ces jeunes adolescents
ça ça s'est fait vraiment au fur et à
mesure ouais ouais ça a été un long
parcours finalement on a eu que quatre
jours de répétition donc c'est passé
quand même assez vite mais voilà le
premier jour a servi aussi beaucoup à
faire connaissance et après petit à
petit des rapports se sont tissés de
manière très très timide au départ et
puis voilà peu à peu quand on a commencé
à monter le spectacle aussi ça a
vraiment servi à faire du lien parce que
au départ il faisait des impro un peu
chacun de son côté et puis quand on a
commencé vraiment à travailler ensemble
à faire du lien entre les scènes etc là
quelque part ils étaient obligés de
parler les uns avec les autres et puis
en fait ça s'est fait quasiment
naturellement quoi des deux côtés et on
l'entend un petit peu dans dans le
reportage alors des deux côtés ils en
tirent des bénéfices une expérience
positive mais est-ce que vous avez eu
aussi d'autres retours enfin est-ce que
vous avez pu échanger avec eux sur sur
ce projet culturel qu'est-ce qu'ils en
ont pensé
non alors avec les migrants pas
directement j'ai changé avec des
personnes de l'association qui m'ont dit
que les retours étaient plutôt positifs
et enfin déjà on le voit en termes de
date parce que le stage on a réalisé fin
février la représentation elle a eu lieu
le 11 mars et du coup il y a quand même
un laps de temps et quand on travaille
avec des publics qui sont divulnérables
c'est vrai que le rapport au temps est
pas tout à fait le même et donc il
pourrait y avoir de la perte entre
guillemets là faut savoir que sur le
stage il y a eu quand même un noyau très
solide il y en a qui sont venus les
quatre jours sur la représentation ils
se sont pas démobilisés non plus donc il
y a eu un vrai enfin voilà ils étaient
vraiment vraiment très investis dans ce
projet quoi et Claire chéri est-ce que
on peut s'attendre à une suite ou est-ce
que il y aura un autre projet culturel
comme comme celui-ci l'année prochaine
peut-être alors certainement en tout cas
nous on y est favorable parce que c'est
vrai que le travail avec Alex a été tout
à fait bénéfique là il l'a rappelé que
le stage n'a duré que quatre jours donc
il y a eu un peu de travail en amont
pour mobiliser
les jeunes et les migrants mais en fait
il a réussi parce qu'il sait ça il sait
faire ça très bien
à les investir très très vite dans le
projet et donc ils nous ont restitués
samedi dernier un projet qui était
vraiment de qualité moi j'ai trouvé tout
à fait bouleversant et très et voilà
émouvant chacun y a mis un peu ses
tripes sur la table donc c'est ça aussi
qui fait que les retours sont positifs
parce que vraiment chacun a vécu ce
moment de façon très intense et donc
nous on est fait on serait ravis de
continuer à travailler avec Alex sur
d'autres d'autres types de projets à
destination de ce public là ou d'autres
en tout cas on a plein de projets pour
le petit moulin dans les mois à venir et
on aura peut-être l'occasion d'en parler
un peu plus tard merci à vous deux
d'avoir accepté notre invitation